we are now going to continue our
discussion of factor markets and we're
going to go beyond just thinking about
labor as a factor in fact in this video
we're going to start thinking about
capital as well which we know is another
one of the factors of production but
just as a little bit of review we've
already thought about it from a firm's
perspective on what is the rational
amount of labor to hire
based on the marginal revenue product of
labor and based on the marginal factor
cost of labor so in the horizontal axis
we have the quantity
of labor
hired by the firm and in the vertical
axis you have the wage rate
wage rate which you could view as the
price of labor and we've seen this
multiple times you're likely to have a
downward sloping
marginal revenue product curve
mrp and i'm going to be very specific
that this one is the marginal revenue
product of labor and then we have the
marginal factor cost curve and if we're
assuming that this firm is in a
competitive perfectly competitive labor
market well they're just going to have
to pay whatever the wage is in the
market and so that's why we have a
horizontal line there so that's the
marginal factor cost
of labor and we've talked about multiple
times that it's rational for the firm to
keep hiring as long as the marginal
revenue product of labor as long as the
incremental revenue that the firm gets
for each of those people or each of
those units of labor that they hire is
higher than the incremental cost of each
of those units of labor and so it'll
keep hiring until these two lines
intersect and so it would be rational
for it to hire that quantity of labor
i'll do this as the labor for the firm
and i'll put a little star over here so
that quantity of labor and we can draw
an analogous thing for capital so this
is
how a firm thinks about that input how
it thinks about labor
but we could also do something similar
for capital
or we could do it for land as well but
hopefully so this is going to be the
firm
the firm as they think about capital
and we'll see that they have
analogous axes
the horizontal axis right over here is
going to be the quantity not of labor
but the quantity of
capital
and then the vertical axis the price of
capital you could view that as the rent
rate
rent rate if you're thinking about maybe
you're renting some type of machinery
and so you will have your marginal
revenue product of capital
we could still imagine that you have
diminishing returns so that's why it's
downward sloping so marginal revenue
product
and we typically use a k for capital
just as we don't get the c confused with
other things and then we have our
marginal factor cost which is really
just and we'll assume once again that
this is a perfectly competitive capital
market so you just have to pay whatever
the market rate for renting that capital
is
and so
that would be the marginal factor cost
of the capital and so once again it
makes sense to keep bringing on more and
more and more capital as long as the
incremental revenue that you get from
each of those extra units of capital is
higher than the cost of each of those
extra units of capital and so here it
would be rational for the firm if we're
just looking at the dimension of capital
to produce this much
so this would be actually let me this
would be the capital the quantity of
capital
for the firm to employ
now an interesting question that might
have already crossed your minds are is
that firms have a certain amount of
resources that they they are going to
think about well how much do i put in
labor versus how much do i put into
capital so they don't just think about
these these dimensions of how many how
much inputs of these factors they want
they have to think about them relative
to each other
and to help us think through this
let's say that we are at a certain level
of output so let's say that our output
right now i don't know
our current output
our current
output
is
i'm just going to make up something 1000
units
per day
and at our current output we know what
the marginal product of labor and the
marginal product of capital is let's say
that we know
that our
marginal product of labor at this output
remember it changes as we have very
different output and we bring on more
labor or more capital so our marginal
product of labor at that level is
units
so another way to think about it for
every incremental unit of labor we bring
on we're going to be able to produce 90
more units of output so this is and then
let's say that the price of labor which
is the wage rate
is equal to ten dollars
ten dollars per unit of labor so let me
call this output units
output units
and let's say that the marginal product
of capital i'm just in a different color
the marginal product of capital right
now
is 80 output units
output
units so every unit of this factor of
capital we are able to produce an
incremental 80 output units and let's
say that the price of capital which
would be the rent
is equal to five dollars
five dollars per input unit of the
factor
so at right at this moment
if i have an incremental dollar would it
be more rational for me to add more
labor or would it be more rational for
me to add more capital pause this video
and see if you can figure that out
well to think about which one is more
rational you just think about which one
do i get more of a bang for my buck so
per dollar how many output units do i
get when i put a dollar into labor
versus per dollar how many output units
do i get when i put that dollar into
capital so let's do it first for labor
so if you want your bang for the buck so
to speak you would just take your
marginal let me do this in a different
color
if you want your bang for a buck you
would just take your marginal product of
labor so your output and divide it by
the price so this is going to tell you
output per dollar and so in this
situation it's 90
output units
could we could say widgets for a general
term for output units
output units over ten dollars over ten
dollars and so this is going to be equal
to nine output units per dollar so this
is equal to nine
output
units
per
dollar so that's our measure of our bang
per bang for our buck when we put an
incremental buck into labor now what
about for capital
well our marginal product of capital
divided by
the price of capital right at this
moment remember it changes depending on
our output level and different
combinations is going to be equal to 80
output
units
divided by five dollars
which is equal to 16
output
units
per
dollar so which one would i get a better
bang for my buck
well right at this moment i'm getting a
better bang for my buck from investing
in capital every extra dollar i put i
get 16 output units so it'd be rational
for this firm that wants to maximize its
profit and reduce its cost if it has an
extra dollar to invest it would put it
into capital
and so maybe it puts it into capital and
then it gets a little bit more output
and then the marginal product of capital
is likely to go down and so you could
imagine at some point these things might
be equal and then the firm might be
indifferent between the two and then
maybe at some point if they keep kept
adding capital then maybe
you get a better bang for your buck from
the labor in general a firm would want
to keep investing in one or the other
until these two things are equal to each
other
so
big picture you would look at the
marginal product of the factor divided
by the price of the factor and then you
compare that to the marginal product of
the other factors divided by the price
of those other factors and whichever one
has the best bang for the buck that's
where it would be rational to invest in
and then you have in some ways your
one way is a very efficient combination
is if you are you get to that point that
you're indifferent when the marginal
product divided by the prices of the
various factors are equal to each other
so for example
if i were to tell you that we're at a
different point of production let me
let me cordon this off
so if we're at a different level of
production where our marginal product of
labor is equal to i'll call it 10
widgets
saves time and let's say that the price
of labor is equal to five dollars and
let's say that the price of capital is
equal to ten dollars what would have to
be the marginal product
of capital
for me to be indifferent between labor
and capital pause this video and try to
figure that out
well in order for me to be indifferent
right over here that means my marginal
product of labor divided by price of
labor needs to be equal to my marginal
product of capital divided by my price
of capital and so i would have 10
over 5
would have to be equal to my marginal
product of capital over 10. so 10 over 5
this is 2 widgets per dollar
and so if i want two widgets per dollar
over here this has got to be equal to
20.
so at this point
i'm indifferent between producing
between bringing on more capital versus
labor because in either case every
dollar i bring on if the marginal
product of capital is 20 then i'm able
to forget two widgets per dollar of
investing in either factor